how many prefectures do you have you
said like four i've got
two prefectures to go to two prefectures
yeah what are there
uh koti in shikoku and
miyazaki which we kind of drove through
on january i mean i can't
can we kill that no no i kind of feel
like we should know i don't know
so miyazaki and kochi and that's it all
right how much yeah and maybe shimane
so that's three do you feel like you've
almost completed japan
i've got my i've got a scratch map of
japan right
and it's got like only a few bits to
scratch off now and then i'll be like
done
what are you gonna do yeah what are you
gonna do after that bits and pieces of
okinawa the pacific islands of japan
like algoshima
have you ever seen it
[Laughter]
got to finish up playing kind of kind of
in the end game now you start doing soap
land reviews
[Music]
scratch the last one
on the summit of mount fuji [ __ ]
yeah i don't know i think but there's
still lots of places in prefectures you
know i've only
passed through some of these prefetches
and there's still lots of things to see
and do
is it getting hard to find video topics
though or you still feel like you're
trying to find this there's still an
endless amount like i've only just made
a video
yesterday on asakusa the district in
tokyo really that most tourists in japan
go to
the most popular sport and when there's
tourists there
but it's a beautiful part is [ __ ]
horrible when there's tourists that's
the shrine right yeah yeah sensation you
also like can't take pictures of that
and post them online we we were filming
and the security guards sort of wandered
up and just came into shop behind us
and we were like oh [ __ ] we can't
film here yeah luckily we got away with
it just in time before we turned up
apparently you get fined though
well if you post it so we'll see bring
it on
bring it on now please don't
that's a promotional video trying to
promote you guys trying to help you
i don't know why they would do that
though it seems a bit of an odd first
japan is so weird
yeah you don't think there's like
hundreds of tourists taking pictures of
it right yeah because like the eiffel
tower is
like private property that you
technically i you know you can't
actually take pictures of
really for commercial use but they do
all the time because
yeah it's just a [ __ ] answer there's
nothing stopping them right yeah i mean
you can't regulate that it's it's it's
literally in the skyline well japan is
like
bet we're gonna try and raise about
filming laws like have you ever been to
a japanese concert
or japanese like you've been to your
concert but i haven't what oh you could
then
let you film it do they no no no no no
no no they don't let you film it yeah
it's it's really like
looked down upon to like film a concert
a live concert whereas
to be honest live in the moment i'm
pretty good about actually well you
can't even like relive the moment
yourself when i when i did the
documentary on hide the rockstar guy
nobody took out their phone you can see
no one apart from the end when he gets
everyone out to put the lights on their
phone
yeah of light they're pretty damn strict
on that
it's it's so that they i don't mind that
though but the reason they do that is so
that they get you to buy
the dvd yeah yeah yeah all right so it's
like
just a promotional spiritual javascript
no i don't appreciate the artist
yeah you have to live in the moment just
buy your [ __ ] message
what the [ __ ] i made so much money from
it i was really impressed well yeah he's
selling [ __ ] credit where's the
abroad in japan
we've got top 14 itunes take that
credit card coming soon credit that's
what i want
it would be a [ __ ] show
what would it do
is just that face